people are fireworks lit up the sky for
Independence Day some people kicked off
the holiday on a much quieter note one
of the rarest and most important
documents in American history a draft
copy of the Declaration of Independence
handwritten by Thomas Jefferson was on
display here in New York this is a
document that we bring out unusually but
we celebrate the 4th of July by showing
to the public this fundamental document
of American liberty and American
independence in a rare showing this week
the New York Public Library displayed
Thomas Jefferson's original manuscript
of the Declaration of Independence bill
Kelley oversees the preservation of such
documents at the library Jefferson had
drafted a version of the Declaration
that the congressional committee and the
Congress edited omitted from the final
version was Jefferson's stance on the
institution of slavery Jefferson was a
slaveholder was strongly opposed to
freeing individual slaves what he wanted
was to eliminate slavery as an
institution and then deport the slaves
who were currently in the United States
one of the reasons why the rest of the
Continental Congress wanted this out was
that it was so contradictory the library
acquired the manuscript at auction in
1896 it has only brought out once a year
due to its fragile nature when not on
display it is kept in a vault to
preserve its condition the library
received thousands of visitors this week
to catch a glimpse of American history
among those was Medal of Honor recipient
David Bellavia to me what I defended was
the Constitution of the United States
and this declaration was really the
precursor to getting that fundamental
document that we all swear an oath to
it's a very special moment as a soldier
to see the document that started the
entire making of the united states the
historic manuscript is back in its vault
for now but will be on permanent display
in november of 2020 so they're building
a special case so that it can be out a
little bit longer but man Mary Ann Keene
was a producer on this piece and she
actually got to see it and she said that
to see it up close you don't think
you're gonna get emotional or actually
sense anything like okay I know this is
coming but she said there's just kind of
this quietness when you're in there and
observing it's an actual piece of
history I know it's just it's different
think about anything you see that's
historic and just want to afford that's
still left in terms of the draft so cool
yeah